[Music]
hello everyone hello everyone very
excited to introduce you to the tracks
of Devcon and some of the people who
have been instrumental in creating their
content um and yeah to be frank I've
never been that loud in a room so I can
tell you I'm super excited um few
numbers first um we had more than 3,000
applications to speak at Devcon this
year more than double what we had in
bota it's pretty amazing to see um yeah
thank you thank you thank
[Applause]
you um and unfortunately we had room for
around only 15% of them um so the
content you'll see here is actually like
the best of the best
um you will see this content Crossing 10
different tracks um and there will be
content there will be something for
everyone so to share a bit more about
them I'd like to invite key reviewers
from each track who have been
instrumental in creating the amazing
content that you'll see at Devcon they
will give a rapid pitch about why each
track match matters what are some
highlights and who is it for so without
further Ado I would like to introduce
Austin for the developer experience
track thank
[Applause]
you so so many incredible talks here at
Devcon uh but like Josh said it's all
about developers uh so the developer
experience track is extra important and
I got to spend a lot of time working
with a lot of tool Builders at the space
to uh help evaluate all of these talks
uh Georgio Rick moo a lot of other
people that I will forget their names
I'm very thankful for your help uh
setting up this lineup but it's
everything from App tooling smart
contract tooling frames debugging ZK
indexers optimizers autonomous worlds
even Community Building uh we'll have a
little bit of everything for developers
um beginner starter kits like scaffold
eth and remix to help you get you know
that first hello world all the way to
very very deep technical content uh huge
range of old school to New School really
cool to see you know like the creator of
truffle giving a talk or the the Python
and the Huffer guys uh the hard hat guys
The Foundry guys uh open Zeppelin ethers
whole whole array of wonderful folks uh
will be speaking shout out to the weam
wagm guys who who aren't here we we uh
we miss them and they are a huge impact
on the space so just to hit it real
quick we're going deep and wide on
tooling it'll be a side of autonomous
worlds and optimizers and Community
Building why because we're literally
building the
future who Builders dreamers creators
Shepherds shippers optimizers debuggers
and data Nerds come check out the
developer experience uh track uh we'll
have a whole Capture the Flag game on
the 13th lots of great stuff uh I'm
going to hand it off to Amy with
usability thank
you all right my name is Amy and I'm
honored to be introducing the usability
track the usability track is all about
improving the user experience of
ethereum we're focused on sharing
patterns and design processes around
user experience onboarding and
accessibility
as you'll see with this speaker variety
of speaker backgrounds usability really
requires an all handson deck approach
designers developers Devils to product
leads we all have to come together to
solve our most pressing adoption
challenges to me Devcon represents a
snapshot of what's most important to our
community as vitalic said this year we
really want to focus on usability with
themes like account abstraction
cross-chain settlement intent
pass Keys mobile ux um these all
highlight key solutions to realizing
ethereum's greater
Vision so in our track alone we had over
300 applications so with six judges you
guys are all the Nerds you can do the
math on how long it took us to review
and deliver it and so with that we're so
excited for you to dig into this track
we hope you leave these talks with fresh
perspective and techniques for improving
usability in your next build so so now I
hand it off to Tim to introduce the next
track hey everyone uh my name is Tim boo
I work at the EF and I help put together
the core protocol track uh for this
year's Defcon so if you want to learn
about what's happening about the to the
ethereum protocol new network upgrade
the future of proof of stake how the evm
is going to evolve how we have tooling
set up to monitor the network changes
the issue and all of those things this
is a track you should be following we'll
be covering the future of the ethereum
protocol starting from things that are
sort of very concrete and about to ship
and as we move through the week things
will get more and more speculative and
you'll get a big sense of like the
overall research road map we do have
content for everyone every level of like
knowledge and depth and expertise um so
if you're new to ethereum uh don't be
intimidated by this show up go see some
of the sessions um but if you're deep
into this we hopefully have some
technical workshops that you'll find
stimulating too to highlight a few of
these um I'll start with Christine's
talk today she'll give an overview of
pectra which is ethereum's next Network
upgrade so if there's a single talk you
want to go to this week to just
understand what's changed in ethereum
this would be it then if you really want
to get your hands dirty and get into the
weeds tomorrow the EF testing team is
running a workshop about how they
actually do testing how we keep the
chain secure how we make sure it never
goes
down and last I want to highlight two of
the community sessions we'll have this
week um all day on Wednesday we have an
EPF day EPF is uh the ef's ethereum
protocol Fellowship oh well cheers for
EPF yeah we could clap for
them um yeah so the ethereum protocol
Fellowship is effectively the ef's way
of bringing in new core devs to help uh
Steward ethereum so we have all of them
here or at least a large majority that
will be presenting the work that they've
done if you've been wondering about how
to get into court development this is a
great place to be if you're a client
team looking the higher core devs then
you go go see their presentations and
then last but not least all day on
Friday we'll have an ethereum magician
session to discuss all of the most
important topic around around ethereum
um we'll have a session covering ux one
about the future of block construction
issuance and the future of the ethereum
protocol where we'll have experts in all
of these topics there to discuss and
have the the room open for the community
to come and ask questions and collabor
thank you very much and I'll see you
across all of
these and S for real world
ethereum hi everybody my name is SII I'm
very very excited to introduce our
awesome track uh this is a new track um
that just got added into the Dacon this
time because of the maturity of the
ethereum that Josh and a and Bali was
mentioning um so this track is focusing
on the real world old use cases so you
can woohoo finally finally we can
actually see some applications that is
actually based and people can use uh so
it's very very exciting and because of
that I think a lot of people were
interested in showing their work so far
that was hidden uh under the ground so
we had a more than 530 Plus application
just for this track and we had to add
more judges to actually do that so L
plge to the older judges including all
of our track doing this amazing reviews
uh but anyway so out of the 530 uh
application we select uh 80 plus
conversation so those conversation you
can find a people who building uh a
financial application in the you know
for example Africa and
alsoi uh rwa uh NGS and government
building uh Identity or like donation
tracking system supply chain there's
just so many use cases that people are
starting are using ethereum to build the
solution so you can meet all of this
conversation in our track um and who is
for actually for everybody uh basically
whoever curious about the real use case
of um ethereum and how you can use it if
you want to imagine what I can do with
ethereum please come this uh track and
this is a four kind of feature track out
of 80 it was really hard to choose those
four but I tried to choose what that is
the most common uh and then have a more
people so we have a
one do you hear the music yeah one with
a next billion fellow so you can hear
people's story and then also there's
other things from the global majority
and the philosophy and all sorts of
different story so please come join our
track next is a goip
hello Devcon I'm gub sheep and I'm
incredibly excited to introduce the
applied cryptography track at this
year's conference this track covers how
the ethereum community is pushing
forwards and engaging with the frontiers
of cryptography from research level
Innovation to production grade global
scale deployment the story of advanced
cryptography in 2024 is deeply
intertwined with the story of ethereum
and this track is for both researchers
developers and technologists but also
for for anyone who is interested in how
different Technologies can help us
realize the future of digital
infrastructure at Devcon this year
you'll have the chance to interact
Hands-On with programmable cryptography
in many ways from speaker Q&A with zero
knowledge proofs uh to zero knowledge
approvable tickets on zoo pass that you
can use to interact with various
applications built by ethereum community
members to interactive games at the
cursive and frog crypto or Prague crypto
boots and Community hubs downstairs
we'll hear from dozens of speakers for
this track covering topics from
cryptography for digital identity to
proof carrying data to program aisc and
Beyond and you can tune into the Devcon
passport app uh for more and be on the
lookout for a certain green and
amphibious friend throughout your Devcon
experience and now Alicia from the
coordination
track thanks GB sheet hi I'm Alicia and
I'm going to talk to you today about the
coordination track so if you're there we
go
uh if you're wondering what coordination
is actually sitting in this room or
being part of Devcon whether you're
sitting in this room or watching um now
or in the future is an incredible
example of the power of coordination and
the impact that it can have on ethereum
so other topics or topics that will be
covered in the coordination track
include Dows governance uh public goods
incentives and tooling and mechanisms
that can help us build resilient and
decentralized
ecosystems so when you think about why
coordination is important we often kind
of default to thinking about technical
Concepts in ethereum and obviously that
makes sense but when you think about it
ultimately it comes down to the
coordination of people involved in those
projects um that's really what
determines the success and growth and
adoption um of Any Given project in the
ethereum ecosystem so I think that you
know the importance of coordination is
the ability of humans to coordinate
across across space and time whether
it's you know different countries many
different time zones that we manag to
get on calls um across languages and
different cultures and experiences um
all coming together for a shared Vision
so I think that I know everyone says
this but I really do think that the
coordination track can appeal to
everyone whether you're new to the
ethereum community or a seasoned veteran
whether you're technical or
non-technical and um this is just a
selection of some of the highlights on
the coordination track uh Dennison Tim
aukee Griff green all incredible
examples of values aligned ethereum and
um really looking forward to seeing you
um enjoy the coordination track and next
up we have Ley
thank you so much Alicia I'm very very
happy that uh this year we have a cipher
Punk track at Defcon and we can expose
so many great people to the ideas and
values of Cipher Punk uh because we are
crafting a very very sharp tool here and
we need to make sure that this tool is
used uh to advance Humanity into a
bright future and not Lo lock Us in in a
dark
dystopia um I want to highlight uh some
sessions I was told to do four but uh I
want to lead by example here to not obey
Authority even though I respect Nathan
uh so I did
six and it was also really really hard
to choose because we had so many great
submissions and that's even only the
submissions that are accepted uh and we
had to reject so many great talks which
was really really sad so a nice
foundational talk can be the history and
philosophy of Cipher Punk um that can
introduce you to the concept so if
you're new to that uh please watch this
and then also like we need to go to the
Next Generation we not only need the old
generation we need the new generation so
MF will give a talk about uh the new
Cipher Punk generation and then it's
also important to burst Bubbles and not
just to be in our web three bubble here
um so break out a little bit so we
invited uh heart mcon from the Lino
foundation and Roger dingledine from
tour to teach us lessons from um from
their EOS systems basically that we
don't have to repeat these mistakes and
can make our own in the end and also
very important I think is uh the battle
for ethereum soul from LF terius uh so
basically between financial nalism and
the fos culture now hope we go more to
the F culture side there and last but
not least like Jared hope he will talk
about corruption YC and the cost on
compliance thank you very much and next
up is Frederick who will talk about the
security
[Applause]
track hi I'm Frederick I am from the
protocol security team at the EF and I'm
super happy to be here to present the
security track so every day we hear
about users developers projects and
exchanges who are getting scammed d Ed
or hacked this is obviously very sad and
bad for the people that this happens to
but I also believe that if we are to
reach Mass adaptation then this is
something that all of us must and can
improve
on so to help improve the security track
are covering topics such as best
practices through the security framework
by the security
Alliance um we have sessions about
security tooling and we have workshops
all of this by some of the best security
people in the
ecosystem I hope that you will leave
some of these sessions with a desire to
help existing initiatives or perhaps
even get new ideas for initiatives and
to help with that we have a new program
called eth rangers.com where you can
apply for a
$25,000 funding uh for spending time
doing public good security work in the
ecosystem and those who are interested
in applying the offensive security
skills that you obtain in these sessions
you can also join the CTF that we have
on Thursday the 14th where anyone can
apply to join and uh share a price pool
of
$50,000 we also have
a big protocol um bug Bounty competition
happening straight up after Devcon with
a price pool of up to $1.5
million next up is barnab with crypto
economics thank you Frederick hi
everyone I'm bab from the robust
incentives group at the etherum
foundation uh here to present the
cryptoeconomics track it's often said
that ethereum is winging it uh sometimes
we are but we rely on a large body of
work uh that's from a new science called
cryp cryptoeconomics it's you can think
of it as a new field uh that blends
cryptography economics mechanism design
distributed systems consensus Theory and
many more other disciplines and so what
happens is eum doesn't have one research
lab it has 100 different uh research
Labs scattered throughout academic
institutions and the industry these labs
are busy cooking up the technology that
powers our protocol and also the many
applications that rely on it so if you
want to hear about what these labs are
up to uh make sure to check out the
talks from our cryptoeconomics
track every talk in the track will bring
you to the frontier but here are four
samples to give you an idea of what you
can expect uh we're going to be talking
about blobs blobs are a new resource
that the etherum protocol is providing
which Powers our rollups we'll have
introductory sessions to give you a leg
up in your journey towards uh crypto
economics we'll have groundbreaking
research such as Robin Hansen well known
for his work on prediction markets among
others and we'll also have talks giving
you a vision of what is possible uh when
the crypto economics are right so we
hope to see you there and I'll now pass
the mic to BK for the L2
[Applause]
track layer twos last but not least so
um in the last year layer TOS have been
one of theot hottest topics in crypto
probably not as hot as mem coins but
certainly the hottest if you focus on
serious crypto applications and right
now we have uh over 100 l2s on mainnet
with probably twice as many about to be
launched and while curating this track
uh we did not let marketing departments
to get in I'm sorry we love you guys
from marketing we really do uh but this
session is actually prepared by
researchers by Builders by enthusiasts
and also you will hear from critics as
well because we still have a lot of
problems to solve and you will hear
about potential Solutions you will get a
chance to have a glimpse about the
future of how ethereum is going to scale
so
um we have prepared uh 30 talks nine
lightning talks two amazing panels and
six workshops and just to wet your
appetite uh I've uh taken the liberty of
just choosing you know uh one from each
category so if you do want to do a deep
dive like jump into the rabbit hole and
understand how ethereum is going to
scale while uh remaining secure and
decentralized uh please consider uh
attending the session thank you
thank
you thank you thank you so much thanks
to all of you uh thanks to you B um and
with that we have covered all the tracks
so again let's give a big thank you to
these track reviewers as well as their
nearly thank you thank you thank you
um we also had about 100 community
members who helped review and curate
this amazing agenda um but there is much
more than just program content at Devcon
and to share more about all the other
things you can do and see at Devcon um I
will I will pass it back to you scy
thank
you awesome thank you naton thank you
all the track reviewers track
participants Community reviewers uh yeah
as naton mentioned there is a lot more
to Devcon than just the programming than
just the content so I'm going to go
through a quick thrival Gra thrival
guide like what do you need to know to
thrive at Devcon over the next 5 to 10
minutes uh I'll keep it quick but this
stuff hopefully is going to be pretty
important for you guys to to figure out
how can you maximize your experience
here at Devcon first thing you'll need
is the Devcon passport app so this isa.
devon. org it's a progressive web app so
you can download it to your phone uh and
use it throughout the conference here on
this app you have everything you need
you have this schedule you can
personalize your agenda you you can even
share your schedule with your friends or
your followers if you want uh and there
is a diva AI so if you have a question
you can go and ask D.A AI it has all of
the track information in there all of
the agenda information uh and should
know a lot about uh uh about Devcon uh
when it hallucinates you can then go ask
a volunteer so keep that in mind uh but
yeah this app is going to be your
probably your your go-to resource for
understanding what's going on at
Devcon uh also the app has live streams
so all all talks and workshops are being
live streamed and are being recorded and
the recording should be available
immediately after each talk is finished
uh and they should all be available in
the app in addition there are
translations so all talks uh or all
mainstage talks on this stage are being
translated uh by human translators like
an army of human translators sitting
behind this stage right now in Thai
Mandarin Vietnamese and Malay uh all
other tracks all other stages are being
translated by AI translations uh into
Thai Mandarin Hindi bangali Vietnamese
Malay Indonesian Burmese KR Filipino uh
and Filipino so yeah if you need that
use those translations uh also all talks
will have Q&A you can see here on the
bottom uh and as a part of ask speaker
questions so we want Devcon to be more
interactive we want you to be able to
participate with the speaker uh and so
through this you can ask questions to
the speakers and they'll be able to
answer the questions at the end of the
talk uh and hopefully this allows all of
us to participate participate a little
bit more in the sessions that we're
seeing uh much of what Devcon will be is
an entry point an entry point into for
beginners maybe discovery of new topics
for experts to expand their boundaries
one form of content that I'd like to
highlight is lightning talks so these
lightning talks will last five minutes
with a two-minute Q&A they're a really
concise way to communicate a point and
they're usually going to be grouped in
similar topics similar themes so if you
want to get a really bang a good bang
for your buck in terms of time and and
and knowledge absorption I I would
suggest checking out the lightning talks
most of them will be on stage four which
is the other side of the venue uh but
they'll be sprinkled in many stages
throughout I also want to mention uh the
gift of giving so all of you have
received or probably selected swag uh I
think this swag is maybe some of the
coolest designed swag we've ever had for
Devcon so if you haven't seen it yet go
check it out uh but what I think the
coolest swag is you probably don't even
know about yet uh we are giving the
Devcon team is giving you all the gift
of giving uh so we are allocating
$250,000 from the Devcon supporter
program to support public good
informational ethereum dashboards there
is a list of 20 dashboards and you all
can help decide which ones deserve more
support we are using quadratic voting
along with a technology called Macy uh
for anti- collusion and uh and we're
verifying attendance and verifying all
of this using zup pass so go vote at
vote. devon. org prove your ticket with
zup pass and vote for your favorite
dashboard uh or your your your many
favorite dashboards uh each attendee
gets 100 voting power H and you can
learn more at that website or you can
find the Macy team at one of the impact
booths here in the impact
Forum tip number four don't just consume
contribute so at Devcon we have much
more than just like normal content where
we speak to you uh this year we have 14
Community hubs these are non-commercial
areas for communities to meet to discuss
to collaborate uh around domains and
themes that are important within the
ethereum ecosystem uh I'm not going to
list them off but you can see them
around the venue as you walk around and
you can see more at this QR that I might
be blocking uh and each of them has
their own programming it's run by its
own community and they would love for
you to stop by and participate so check
it out devon. org experiences we also
have discussion corners and meeting
rooms available for book B booking by
anyone so if you would like to organize
your own discussion we have four
discussion Corners around the venue they
fit up to 40 people and they can be
booked at reserve. devon. org uh and uh
meeting rooms as well uh number five we
have community-led sessions Community Le
sessions are basically uh are are are
types of content where we allow the
community to curate their content uh so
we have like their full day sessions
where they're Focus around some specific
topic two that might be interesting are
uh one is daac Discovery day on Thursday
where we discuss uh um uh how ethereum
fits into the broader context of
technological innovation AI debates uh
defensive technology uh and other things
uh then there's also mud day on uh on
Thursday as well uh so some people here
might argue that ethereum's greatest
impact is creating Unstoppable Virtual
Worlds if you're one of those Maybe you
can check this out or if you want to
just create really uh efficient and
Powerful onchain applications mud is a
great framework uh and there's a few
others that you heard the track
Representatives uh talk about earlier so
you can check those out on the
app and lastly the Devcon Improvement
proposals so every year we allow the
community to get involved in Devcon and
propose Integrations or ways in which we
can we can extend Devcon the first one
is with zpass so you are all using Z two
pass to manage your tickets uh all of
your tickets are cryptographic
attestations in this form of a pod H and
all of these pods are compatible with
this second generation cryptography of
zero knowledge proofs a and other things
and if you want to learn more about this
you can check out the Frog crypto
Community Hub uh on the first on the
ground floor maybe get yourself a frog
hat H and there's also a a CLS a
community lead session on Friday all
around this technology uh we also have a
music stage on the ground floor where we
have the ethereum open source orchestra
playing from different members of the
ethereum community if you play you can
go maybe join them and lastly I will
mention that we have a treasure hunt
from a team from the community uh I
won't say much more about this other
than this is your first clue so I'll
leave that there for a second uh and if
you want more you can go to this website
or ask Diva AI
and the best tip of all is that this is
a Choose Your Own Adventure event right
you don't need to sign up to talks ahead
of time you should go do what you are
most interested in doing uh what you are
most interested in seeing so in 30
minutes there are talk starting in other
rooms but right now we have someone very
special to to come talk
uh with this I would like to formally
close the opening ceremony part and
welcome to the stage a renowned
expert in technology and Innovation
someone who has been instrumental in
shaping taiwan's digital landscape and
promoting open governance to the
world let's see